[Música]
aos 11 anos
a gente tinha que fazer uma apresentação
na escola aquelas apresentações de final
de ano
e ali eu vi uma oportunidade eu tinha
certeza que eu era apaixonada por um
coleguinha eu ficava envergonhada
vermelha e sonhava em dar meu primeiro
beijo nele
então eu acho que eu era realmente
apaixonada por ele e aí eu resolvi
escrever o roteiro de uma peça teatral a
onde eram adolescentes que tinham
aventuras e que havia uma menina mais
humilde e que no final acabaria ficando
com o boy mais descolado da turma enredo
super original
no caso ele é e pra minha grande alegria
o enredo foi aprovado
maravilha fomos para os ensaios no
primeiro ensaio uma colega se atravessou
e pegou o papel de protagonista e eu
fiquei olhando até hoje aquela história
acontecer eu fiquei furiosa muito
indignada com ela mas comigo porque eu
abri mão da minha história porque eu
deixei que alguém ocupasse o meu lugar
nessa mesma época eu comecei a ter
consciência de que casais eram
diferentes de que existiam basicamente
dois tipos de casais aqueles casais que
eram felizes bem humorados e que o amor
parecia transbordar entre eles e um
outro tipo de casal aonde as agressões
as ofensas e ódio parecia imperar a uma
realidade que vivia com os meus pais em
casa e eu comecei a me perguntar por que
pessoas que à parte
simplesmente não gostam umas das outras
ficam juntas porque a gente tem esse
tipo de atitude porque a gente faz o que
faz e essas questões foram me
acompanhando ao longo do meu crescimento
e acabaram me levando para um caminho
natural que foi escolher a psicologia ea
psicanálise como uma forma de entender
mas muito mais do que isso como uma
forma de ajudar as pessoas a fazerem
melhores escolhas
ninguém merece devidas ruins
era isso que eu pensava e eu encontrei
na profissão uma das minhas paixões é
essa é de tentar ajudar as pessoas a que
as suas escolhas sejam mais interessante
seja mais agradáveis sejam mais
saudáveis para elas para os filhos pra
quem está ao redor por mais de duas
décadas eu venho colecionando histórias
de pessoas com os seus conflitos com
seus sofrimentos com as suas operações
mas especificamente nos últimos 15 anos
até como hobby até como um interesse
pessoal eu comecei a colecionar
histórias histórias do 1º encontro das
pessoas daquele momento que um casal
sempre tem um dia um né sempre tem um
momento inaugural o que conecta as
pessoas e eu passei a escutar ea
escrever essas histórias e eu quero
compartilhar uma história com vocês
a história de joão e clara joão um
profissional super competente 40 anos
divorciado estava lá no seu aplicativo
de relacionamento olhando aquele
cardápio infindável de possibilidades e
de repente se depara com clara e de um
curtir clara quilômetros distante dali
tinha recebido várias curtidas né e
selecionou joão curtir de volta os dois
naquele mesmo dia resolveram matar o
encontro e foram às cegas para um
encontro marcaram num bar super badalado
clara 35 anos profissional super
competente também e também divorciado
foram pro bar joão chegou antes para
tomar uma cervejinha e dá aquela
relaxada básica
quando ele vê clara entrando e aí ele
sentiu uma emoção assim um pouquinho
diferente e pensou acertei na escolha e
clara foi até a mesa eles começaram a
conversar e aquilo foi rolando aquilo
foi tendo uma atração maior clara foi se
sentindo traída pela inteligência pelo
humor e pela provocação dele e ela
impensa ou tem alguma coisa diferente
nesse cara também que o papo foi rolando
o bar foi bombando cada vez mais e teve
um momento uma fração de segundos em que
o olhar dos dois se cruzou e foi como se
só eles estivessem naquele lugar
isso já aconteceu com vocês
aquele momento que a gente sente que vai
rolar e rolou e joão e clara ficaram
naquele encontro a atração foi crescendo
foram tendo outros encontros encontros
em que eles queriam só ficar entre eles
só os dois
e aí começou a acontecer uma outra coisa
com eles eles foram tendo cada vez
vontade mais de ficar juntos
quando eles pensavam no outro mão suava
rosto ficava vermelho coração pulsava
outras partes do corpo pulsava também e
aí o que aconteceu eles estavam
apaixonados e quem já se apaixonou sabe
como
é isso a gente quer ficar grudado a
gente quer ficar colado com a pessoa mas
ainda bem que existem outras coisas na
vida que não só a paixão senão
humanidade nem existiria e o que começou
a acontecer com joão e clara foi que
entre o encontro apaixonado e outro eles
foram mandando mensagem se interessando
pela vida um do outro fazendo elogios
entre eles e aí eles entraram num outro
registro
eles começaram a se amar o amor é como
uma ponte entre um momento de paixão e
outro uma ponte que um de cada lado
constrói diariamente com o interesse com
elogio com positividade e isso aconteceu
com joão e clara
hoje eles têm dois filhos dois dogs um
projeto de vida juntos
se a vida deles vai continuar assim
nessa construção
a gente não sabe eles não têm garantias
amor não é um lugar de garantia ou é
essa história não é do joão e da clara
essa podia ser uma história de cada um
de nós é uma história de pessoas que
mesmo tendo passado por situações
difíceis
mesmo tendo tido o coração machucado
porque eles vinham de outros
relacionamentos
ainda assim eles resolveram se entregar
para uma paixão e construir um amor
nós temos na nossa cultura e no nosso
mapa psicológico
a idéia de que alguém vai nu suprir que
a gente vai encontrar o par ideal é que
a gente vai encontrar o menino cavalo
branco ea mulher perfeita que a gente
não vai se frustrar
e os relacionamentos vão ser como aquele
comercial de margarina
então a gente idealiza
vou contar a história de maria pra vocês
maria era uma profissional super plugada
conectar disse sima e independente
rompeu o relacionamento de longa data
e ela imediatamente já saiu pronta para
se resolver se relacionar com outras
pessoas
isso é o que ela dizia ela ia baladas
não se negava a conhecer absolutamente
ninguém
na prática o que acontecia era que ela
dizia um era alto demais
tinha dinheiro de - era gordo era mago
era muito intelectual não tinha diploma
ou seja maria encontrava enfim david
desculpas porque na verdade ela não
tinha genuinamente se aberto para um
relacionamento
isso se passaram dez anos e foi só
quando ela fez uma retrospectiva foi
quando ela pode olhar para dentro dela
pra valer e quando ela decidiu de fato
que ela estava aberta
foi só aí que ela conheceu o don rua
numa festa à fantasia o amor da vida
dela até hoje só nesses momentos é que a
gente consegue se entregar pra valer
ouvindo centenas de histórias estudando
eu gostaria de compartilhar com vocês
algumas conclusões
a primeira delas é que a gente se
conecta sempre pelo olhar e
invariavelmente esse momento em que
ninguém explica
nem a neurociência vai explicar até hoje
de uma forma completa é aquilo que ainda
tem uma dose de humanidade de magia e
que a gente sente que ali pode
entregar a segunda conclusão é que
muitos momentos a gente tem que romper
com paixões nocivas porque na
contabilidade geral a gente tem que todo
dia ainda escolher aquela pessoa com a
qual a gente acorda do lado bem não todo
todo dia né mas um saldo final a gente
precisa ter mais dias em que a gente diz
quero estar contigo de novo senão a
gente tem que romper com histórias que
são nocivas
nós nos apaixonamos muitas vezes por
situações ruins por pessoas que não nos
fazem bem naquele momento a terceira
conclusão é de que a gente precisa
ressignifica feridas
as histórias que aconteceram ruins com
cada um de vocês com cada um de nós
essas histórias não podem ser restritas
não tem como a gente esquecer mas a
gente pode dar um sentido diferente e
isso é tarefa nós porque é que a gente
vai carregar uma vida inteira uma ferida
seja ela da ordem que for seja de casais
seja da nossa história pessoal entre um
amor ideal de margarina de mídia social
de tudo perfeito e não ter
relacionamento nenhum seja por medo ou
seja por escolha a gente pode escolher o
amor possível imperfeito cheio de
problemas mas aquele em que a gente
cresce junto àquele em que a gente pode
se doar e receber ainda assim uma dose
de amor
a última conclusão é que os casais mais
felizes são aqueles que não economizam
tempo elogios bom humor
e sexo entre eles certo economiza um
pouco de dinheiro que é pra poder fazer
tudo isso fica muito bem e muito bacana
entre a gente
quando eu estava preparando o final
dessa fala eu não consegui
eu sofria o tempo inteiro e por mais que
eu escrevesse reescrevesse estudar se
pensar se não conseguir encerrar de uma
forma que eu pudesse transmitir aquilo
que eu queria falar eu me atrapalhava
e aí eu entendi que isso tem a ver com
os relacionamentos e que as histórias
quando são boas a gente não quer botar
um ponto final mas ciclos acabam pessoas
passam pela nossa vida
então é fundamental que a gente consiga
saber o momento de encerrar mas é muito
importante que a gente saiba que o amor
é uma decisão e que a gente pode decidir
não se sabotar a gente pode de se
dividir a vida com alguém a gente pode
ter escolhas que sejam saudáveis para
nós
não se trata de ter um relacionamento
perfeito se trata de se dar o direito de
poder ter uma vida mais humana se trata
de ter o direito que a gente possa se
entregar num campo de confiança
eu desejo que vocês assim como eu se
algum de vocês precisa fazer um
exercício diário de se lembrar do amor
próprio de um respeito a si de um
respeito ao outro de um carinho e desejo
que vocês possam se entregar
há paixões boas que vocês possam
construir todos os amores possíveis que
passarem na vida de vocês do meu coração
o coração de vocês
meu muito obrigado
[Aplausos]